[Musique]
vingt ans après l amérique rend hommage
aux 3000 morts du 11-septembre des
avions détournés par al-qaïda s'écrasait
sur des sites américains dont les tours
jumelles du world trade center joe biden
qui a présidé cette cérémonie aux côtés
de ses prédécesseurs notamment barack
obama et bill clinton une commémoration
sous fond de retrait chaotique des
américains en afghanistan
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous il est 20h bienvenue sur
si vous nous rejoignez sur rt france à
la une ce soir vingt ans après à
l'amérique rend hommage aux 3000 morts
du 11 septembre
l'attentât le plus meurtrier de
l'histoire américaine et qui a impacté
le monde entier ce matin-là quatre
avions étaient détournés par des
terroristes d'al qaïda deux d'entre eux
se sont écrasés sur les tours jumelles
du world trade center un mémorial il a
été construit depuis et c'est ici que la
cérémonie officielle a eu lieu thomas
bonnet notre correspondant aux états
unis a suivi cet hommage pour nous
thomas bonjour alors l'ambiance était
très lourd dans cette après-midi on
imagine parfaitement une atmosphère
particulière
oui l'heure était à la commémoration aux
hommages pour les personnes qui ont
perdu la vie pour les héros aussi qui
ont aidé justement à sauver des vies le
jour du 11 septembre 2001 alors il ya eu
donc cette cérémonie d'hommage qui a
démarré assez tôt ici aux alentours de 8
heures heure locale et il ya eu
plusieurs moments forts des moments de
recueillement des minutes de silence qui
ont été observés et puis les noms des
quelques trois mille victimes du 11
septembre ont été lus par justement des
familles des victimes et cela s'est
achevée il ya assez peu de temps
finalement parce qu'évidemment il ya eu
beaucoup de noms qui ont donc été cité
lors de cette cérémonie et puis beaucoup
de gens ont décidé de venir aussi
assisté à cet hommage ou en tout cas à
se rendre à proximité de ground zero pas
très loin de là où nous sommes c'est
juste derrière moi il ya beaucoup
d'américains qui ont fait le choix
justement de venir pour des raisons
parfois très différentes certains
préféré rendre hommage à une partie des
héros par exemple qui ont aidé à sauver
bien des vies lors de ces attentats on a
aussi vu par exemple des personnes rhône
hommage aux pompiers on a aussi beaucoup
vu de famille qui justement se rendait à
cette cérémonie puisque vous le savez
cette cérémonie était réservé justement
aux familles des victimes elles
arboraient un ruban bleu ciel et parfois
elle avait aussi des cadres des
portraits parfois même des t-shirts à
l'effigié et bien des êtres chers
qu'elles ont perdu le jour des attentats
du 11 septembre et puis quelques
messages politiques aussi arboré par
certains américains notamment autour
évidemment de la guerre en afghanistan
mais en tout cas le son de cloche était
assez unanimes d'abord rendre hommage à
ceux qui ont perdu perdu la vie et puis
transmettra aux nouvelles générations et
bien le choc qu'a représenté cette
attaque ces attaques contre les états
unis il ya maintenant 20 ans alors
thomas des commémorations qui ont été
également l'occasion d'attaquer le
président biden
oui beaucoup de critiques autour de ces
commémorations un contexte très
particulier pour le président américain
d'une part parce qu'il y a donc et bien
cette crise en afghanistan ce retrait
chaotique des troupes américaines il est
la cible de très nombreuses critiques
depuis maintenant plusieurs semaines des
critiques y compris de la part de
familles de victimes du 11 septembre je
pense notamment à la soeur d'un des
pilotes d'un des avions qui a été
détourné il ya 20 ans qui s'est montré
très critique sur les différentes
antennes américaines où elle a été
interrogée ces derniers jours beaucoup
de critiques donc entre autres joe biden
est évidemment celui qui s'est montré le
plus dur peut-être aujourd'hui c'est
donald trump qui est vous le savez n'a
pas participé à ces commémorations il y
avait trois présidents en exercice de
l'ancien président joe biden barack
obama bill clinton les trois présidents
démocrates des états unis met donc pas
de donald trump ni de george w bush qui
lui était au mémorial pour le vol est
bien 93 et donc donald trump a lui
publié un message vidéo où il a d'abord
rendu hommage aux forces de l'ordre aux
pompiers qui ont servi il ya 20 ans mais
aussi et surtout pour critiquer très
vivement joe biden je propose d'écouter
le leader de notre pays et passer pour
un idiot et cela n'aurait jamais dû se
produire c'est le résultat d'une
mauvaise planification d'une faiblesse
incroyable et de leaders qui n'ont rien
compris à ce qui se passait c'est le 20e
anniversaire de cette guerre et cela
aurait dû être l'année de la victoire de
l'honneur de la force au lieu de cela
joe biden et son administration inapte
on transformer cela en défaite
son cloche totalement différent de la
part de kamala harris et de george
w.bush qui ont eux appelé à l'unité même
fait part de leurs craintes quant à la
désunion qui guette les états unis
évidemment en référence aux différents
débats aux différentes controverses qui
ont eu lieu ces derniers mois on pose là
aussi de les écouter
dans les semaines et les mois qui ont
suivi les attentats du 11 septembre
j'étais fier de diriger un peuple
impressionnant résilient et une si on
parle de l'unité de l'amérique c'est
ensemble lointain une forme maligne
semble à l'oeuvre dans notre vie
quotidienne qui transforme chaque des
accords en dispute et chaque dispute en
choc des cultures une grande partie de
notre politique est devenue un appel
brut à la colère à la peur et à la
rancoeur cela nous rend inquiet pour
notre nation et notre avenir commun
après le 11 septembre nous avons pu voir
comment la peur peut être utilisé pour
semer la division dans notre nation
lorsque des américains sic et musulmans
ont été pris pour cible en raison de
leur apparente leur culte
mais nous avons également vu ce qui se
passe lorsque tant d'américains dans
l'esprit de notre nation se sont montrés
solidaires de tous les peuples et de
leurs concitoyens de ceux qui subissent
la violence et la discrimination
voilà donc pour les appels à l'unité de
george w bush et de kamala harris qui
tranche évidemment avec le discours de
donald trump en tout cas dont un
contexte particulier autour de joe biden
cible de critiques pour ces
commémorations et qui on rappelle a
perdu une grande part de sa cote de
popularité depuis maintenant plusieurs
semaines merci beaucoup thomas pour
toutes ces précisions thomas abonnés en
direct de new york le 11 septembre vingt
ans après on en parle tout de suite avec
régis le sommier grand reporter pour rt
france et avec olivier py thomas avocat
au barreau de washington et auteur de
kamala harris est la pionnière de
l'amérique aux éditions plon
messieurs bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
ce soir sur rtl france alors pour
commencer olivier répétons je me tourne
vers vous on a entendu la
vice-présidente kamala harris également
george deubeuliou bush appelait à
l'unité mais au fond cette cérémonie est
ce qu elle était vraiment sous le signe
de l'unité aujourd'hui aux états unis
il y avait une unité de façade et il y
avait un combat politique derrière unité
de façade elle a été rappelée aussi bien
par joe joe biden que par aude george w
bush c'est l'idée de magnifier la geste
américaine et en particulier l'héroïsme
que ce soit celui des passagers du vol
qui s'est écrasé en pennsylvanie que ce
soit celui des pompiers et des policiers
qui ont participé à son sauvetage des
des personnes au moment des attentats ça
c'est la partie je dirais oecuméniques
et puis derrière il ya néanmoins
incontestablement un vrai combat
politique où on met les images de kamala
harris qui met davantage l'accent sur le
fait de ne pas s'en prendre aux
populations qui pourraient avoir été
discriminés en particulier les musulmans
george deubeuliou bush qui parlait lui
davantage de résilience mais en fait le
problème de george bush c'était moins le
11 septembre que ce qui s'est passé
après le 11-septembre et sa
responsabilité dans les conséquences du
11 septembre et puis donald trump et
bien donald trump lui est véritablement
en campagne donc on est vraiment là
passé à de la politique intérieure
américaine et donc contrairement à ce
qui s'était passé il ya dix ans lors du
première lors de l'anniversaire des dix
années en 2011 c'est-à-dire quelques
mois après l'exécution de ben laden le 2
mai 2011 vous n'avez l'unité de la
nation américaine là en revanche on est
toujours dans la fracturation qu'elle
soit politique ou idéologique alors
régis le sommier rien d'entendre un
combat politique vous pendant toutes ces
années de guerre vous êtes allé à
plusieurs reprises sur le terrain
est ce que par rapport à ce que vous
avez vu la stratégie militaire
américaine
est-ce qu'elle était vouée finalement à
l'échec dès le départ en fait le
problème c'est qu'il ya deux guerres qui
ont été menées par les états unis de
façon concomitante la première l'a
souvent appelé une guerre de nécessité
c'était celle qui a été déclenchée à
partir d'octobre novembre 2001 en
réponse directe aux attentats du world
trade center parce qu'il fallait porter
le fer dans le berceau d'al-qaïda là où
le sanctuaire plutôt là où les kamikazes
avaient été recrutés et toute la
logistique d'al qaïda se trouvait et en
particulier ben laden donc il ya eu
cette guerre qui a été menée en partie
par des forces spéciales d'ailleurs
avait allié aux hommes ce qu'on appelait
l'alliance du nord contre les talibans
et qui en quelques mois a renversé le
gouvernement taliban et ensuite
progressivement en afghanistan il ya eu
une sorte de paix civile qui s'est fait
et jusque vers les années 2005 on dira
qu'il y avait moins de problèmes et que
l'activité
insurgés étaient
minimales et en fait qui s'est passé
c'est que il ya eu la guerre en irak et
cette guerre en irak n'était plus du
tout une guerre de nécessité
mais une guerre de choix une guerre du
chou du choix des dirigeants américains
et on peut dire qu'aujourd'hui une
partie énorme de la responsabilité de ce
qui peut se passer dans le monde et de
la tempête de feu qui a couru sur tout
le moyen-orient est en partie liée
justement à cette intervention
américaine en irak à cette guerre de
choix c'est pierre qui tenait absolument
pas nécessaire et quand on voit george
bush aujourd'hui il se garde bien de
parler de cet aspect de son héritage est
en tout cas ce qu'a fait ce qu'on fait
les états unis en irak et en afghanistan
et moi ce que j'ai pu voir au contact et
ça c'est vraiment des expériences de
terrain au contact de l'armée irakienne
au contact de l'armée afghane c'est
qu'on a essayé de former des armées
nationales on a essayé de me 2 en fait
dans des pays où le maillage tribale où
le maillage ethnique ou les rapports
entre les différentes ethnies sont
extrêmement complexes à parce que
souvent ce sont des pays acp unité très
fragile l'irak est un pays qui a été
fait mais je dirais par l' empire
britannique l'afghanistan est un pays
qui n'avait probablement jamais été
totalement gouverner et ces pays là en
fait vouloir plaquer ce modèle
occidental je parle juste d'un point de
vue militaire parce qu'on a essayé de le
faire au niveau civil eh bien c'était
une erreur parce que on agissait comme
si
il existait des facto une armée
nationale on agissait comme si cette
armée nationale devait ressembler à la
nôtre est tout simplement pour vous dire
les différences ethniques en afghanistan
et les différences tribales sont tels
que on peut pas avoir un colonel par
exemple tadjik qui va gouverner à des
pachtouns ops et voilà et le problème de
cette structure comment occidentale de
l'armée c'est qu'elle n'a jamais
fonctionné cet art mais là ça peut
expliquer en partie aussi l'échec de
l'armée afghane trois cent mille hommes
contre 75 mille talibans qui ont par
contre maîtrise à merveille toutes les
comment les ramifications et les
rapports techniques du pays et en fait
c'est l'échec qu'il est là il est
d'avoir voulu plaquer militairement et
d'avoir voulu faire des armées
nationales qui n'ont jamais fonctionné
et au niveau de l'administration civile
ça a été exactement la même chose ce qui
s'est passé en irak est un cas d'école
on a donné le pouvoir en irak aux
chiites à travers les élections et du
coup on a la classe qui gouvernait le
pays avant c'est-à-dire les arabes
sunnites c'est à dire ceux qui étaient
autour de saddam hussein sont devenus
des citoyens de seconde classe et ses
citoyens de seconde classe se sont
vengés en créant des ch on peut dire que
des ch quelque part c'est la vengeance
de saddam hussein et une réponse aussi
qui montre qu'on n'a pas été capable de
proposer une alternative vous savez ce
qu'on a reproché souvent à george bush a
dick cheney et à toute l'administration
à mini e américaine c'est de ne pas
avoir pensé à la phase après la chute de
bagdad cette cette phase là il n'a
jamais été envisagé nulle part et du
coup le pays est resté donc voilà comme
ça il n'y a pas eu de solution apportée
il n'y en a pas eu non plus en
afghanistan donc le problème de ces
interventions américaines de ces guerres
messianique au nom de la démocratie
contre la dictature contre
l'obscurantisme ces quatre ont été
faites avec des mentalités d'occidentaux
avec l'idée de plaquer sur des pays qui
n'avaient pas cet héritage qui n'avait
pas cette culture notre culture et tous
les chèques aujourd'hui en irak et en
afghanistan et est allée devant nous ces
pays sont détruits jean j'y rajoute ray
la libye également nous français et
anglais puisque nous avions le lead sur
cette guerre ah non voulues comment
remplacer les dictateurs avons voulu
rapporter la démocratie en libye en
réalité la conséquence a été qu'on a
effectivement déboulonner le dictateur
que le pays est en ruine aujourd'hui
mais qu'en plus il nous oblige à être
présents au sahel parce que l'ondé de
choc de la libye les arsenaux de kadhafi
les armes de kadhafi on les a retrouvés
pour armer les colonnes de djihadistes
alliés aux touareg qui ont foncé sur
bamako et c'est pour ça que nous sommes
intervenus dans le cadre de l'opération
serval et c'est pour ça que nous sommes
toujours au sahel
à cause de cette instabilité créé par la
déstabilisation de la libye au fond
olivier python l'ex président donald
trump quand il dénonce l'incompétence de
joe biden aujourd'hui finalement depuis
george deubeuliou bush est ce que tous
les présidents américains ont une part
égale de responsabilité dans la
situation que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
un canevas idéologique qui en fait a été
à peu près mise en place de la fin
d'où la chute du mur en 1991
jusqu'au 15 août 2021 c'est à dire
jusqu'au jusqu'à l'arrivée des talibans
au retour des talibans à kaboul vous
avez d'abord une période qui va de 80 à
2001 jusqu'au 11 septembre où vous avez
une amérique hyper puissance mais hyper
puissance dans l'absolu qui entame un
certain nombre d'interventions
militaires ont pas ce qu'on pense en
particulier à l'ex yougoslavie et la
somme elle qui se passe plutôt bien à
part la somalie bien sûr et où les
etats-unis bénéficient d'une part de la
faiblesse de la chine qui n'est pas le
géant que l'on utilise aujourd'hui qu'il
est aujourd'hui et en même temps si vous
voulez delà de la faiblesse structurelle
d'une russie qui n'est plus l'union
soviétique et donc pendant une dizaine
d'années les états unis interviennent de
manière massive militairement et
commence à mettre en place ce fameux
concept dont on a entendu parler de
nation building d'ailleurs le fait de
reconstruire de reconstituer de
transformer une région du monde anguille
incluant à la force de manière forcée
les valeurs occidentales et en partie la
démocratie 2001 marque une rupture c'est
à dire qu'à ce moment là comme l'avait
dit un certain nombre de penseurs et
d'analystes américains l'amérique
devient le problème et n'était plus la
solution c'est à ce moment là que débute
la guerre en afghanistan puis la guerre
en irak puis les interventions ciblées
en syrie puis les menaces sur l'iran et
là on se rend compte que cet
interventionnisme pour répondre à votre
question il est global et grosso modo
accepté bon an mal an par l'ensemble de
la classe politique pas forcément la
population et la classe politique qui
est d'accord sur cet interventionnisme
qui est une sorte d' interventionnisme
messianique et puis il ya la lassitude
de la guerre que donald trump a sans
doute compris que
jean balde n'avait compris aussi tour
est tout à fait objectif est donc cette
lassitude de l'opinion publique s'est
concrétisée par un retrait par une
volonté de retrait des troupes
militaires et des troupes en
une opération extérieure militaire et en
particulier en afghanistan
or
hors du deschamps de des champs
d'intervention est de retour aux états
unis donald trump l'avait
conceptualiser et et avaient entamé leur
retrait joe biden l'a fait dans leur
manière de la façon dont on le sait il y
aura énormément de critiques à formuler
sur la manière dont il l'a fait mais ce
changement il date de 4 5 ans où
effectivement le constat d'échec il est
réel il est totale et surtout il est
consensuel c'est peut-être l'un des
rares sujets consensuels au sein de la
société américaine je parle du retrait
des troupes américaines et du retour à
la maison démocrates comme républicains
étaient d'accord sur le principe donc on
a totalement fait une révolution
copernicienne à par rapport à ce
qu'avait décidé les néoconservateurs on
est passé à autre chose maintenant
l'histoire retiendra la manière dont ça
s'est déroulé et en particulier les fans
aux attentats de kaboul mais
incontestablement on est en train de
passer dans une troisième phase qui est
une phase de repli qui est une phase
aussi de doutes la société américaine
n'est plus sûre en tout cas elle a
compris que
l'action militaire ne réglait pas les
problèmes que ça lui en poser davantage
et que ça la rendait pas retirement
impopulaire reste à savoir avec d'autres
acteurs ou particulier la chine comment
le monde l'avenir du monde va s'écrire
mais en tout cas aujourd'hui enfin
depuis une quinzaine de jours depuis le
retrait de bacs de kaboul une page de
l'interventionnisme américain a été
tournée et on va passer à autre chose à
une autre phase merci tous les deux on
arrive malheureusement au terme du temps
qui nous est imparti en tous les cas
merci pour votre analyse votre
décryptage merci à vous régis le sommier
on vous connaît grand reporter pour arte
france merci à vous olivier py ton
avocat au barreau de washington et
auteur de kamala harris la pionnière de
l'amérique aux éditions plon
et après c'est attaquer les états unis
ont voulu se doter d'une nouvelle
législation c'est le patriot act un
texte officiel qui a donné plein pouvoir
aux agences de renseignement
un texte toujours en vigueur le point
avec katia technique
depuis les attentats du 11 septembre
2001 le monde est devenu plus sombre
parce qu'ils ont déclenché des guerres
qui ont contribué à embraser le
moyen-orient mais aussi à cause des
mesures sécuritaires et législatives qui
ont fleuri en occident où l'on chérit
pourtant traditionnellement les libertés
publiques la lutte antiterroriste et
pour effet de les restreindre dans le
monde entier c'est là l'erc lancé par le
président d'honneur de la fédération
internationale pour les droits humains
life idh l'avocat patrick baudouin dans
l'hebdomadaire marianne
depuis le 11 septembre les opinions
publiques s'acclimate aux restrictions
de liberté aux états unis où le patriot
act a été confortée en 2015 l'année ses
a annoncé avoir mis fin à son programme
de collecte de données téléphoniques et
pour cause ça ne marchait pas mais la
surveillance de masse a muté en un autre
monstre désormais la police pour des
affaires de routine combat le crime avec
des moyens techniques développées pour
l'antiterrorisme reconnaissance faciale
kamian rayons x prise de photos
continuelle caméra analyse des réseaux
sociaux bienvenue dans le meilleur des
mondes et cela a des conséquences
particulièrement effrayante comme la
mésaventure survenue à des ricains g
simple participant à une manifestation
blacklight matters à new york l'été 2020
il avait commis l'irréparable crime de
crier dans une corne de brume près d'un
officier de police grâce à la
reconnaissance faciale les enquêteurs
ont retrouvé son profil sur les réseaux
sociaux ils ont espionné son domicile
avec un drone et des dizaines de
policiers en armes sont venus l'arrêter
avec un hélicoptère et de nombreuses
voitures en renfort on ne suis pas une
mouche avec un marteau toutes les
charges envers l'accusé ont été
abandonnées mais quelle perspective
glaçante le développement d'un appareil
sécuritaire propre à violer les droits
du citoyen s'est étendue sur le monde
déjà en 2016 amnesty international
protesté au lendemain d'une série
d'attentats de paris à berlin les
gouvernements ont adopté à la hâte une
multitude de lois discriminatoires et
disproportionné de nouvelles lois
radicale mais l'europe vers un état de
sécurisation permanente enracinée et
dangereux en allemagne depuis 2006 la
loi permet d'utiliser des données
personnelles d'individus suspecté d'être
en lien avec des activités terroristes
rassemblés dans une base de données
gérée par l'office fédéral de la police
criminelle la surveillance généralisée a
fini par s'imposer l'allemagne a adopté
en 2010 est une loi sécuritaire
controversé la collecte des données de
messagerie crypté comme moi de sap ou
skype elle sera autorisée dans le cadre
de procédures pénales elles ne l'étaient
avant cela que dans le cadre des
enquêtes pour terrorisme
en grande bretagne une loi
l'antiterrorisme 'crime and security act
fut promulguée le 14 décembre 2001
plusieurs autres ont suivi avec des
extensions de garde à vue autre
restriction de liberté comme l'accès à
la navigation d'un suspect la
restriction de mouvement en juin 2006 un
juge de haute cour à déclarer illégal le
maintien en régime d'assignation à
résidence renforcer prévues par la loi
autre exemple depuis 20 ans l'australie
a promulgué 92 loi anti terroriste au
nom de la sécurité nationale
la divulgation d'informations sensibles
par la presse peut être sévèrement
réprimée en france dès le 15 novembre
2001 la loi renforcer les pouvoirs des
agents de police judiciaire ou des
agents de sécurité privés pour les
contrôles d'identité à la suite de
l'état d'urgence consécutifs aux
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 est venue
la loi sur la sécurité intérieure et la
lutte contre le terrorisme dite loi sylt
en octobre 2017 le conseil
constitutionnel a souvent rejeté les
articles les plus sécuritaires mais il a
validé en 2021 la plupart des mesures de
la loi antiterroriste portée par le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
elle implique la fermeture de lieux de
culte le contrôle administratif et de
surveillance le développement de
l'intelligence artificielle
le député insoumis ugo bernalicis a
dénoncé ce projet de loi qui fait
glisser selon lui par un régime de plus
en plus autoritaire certes des dizaines
d'attentats terroristes ont heureusement
était déjoué ces dernières années mais
il ne faudrait pas que comme aux états
unis les mois de l'anti terrorisme
soient déployés pour contrôler et
réprimer d'innocents citoyens français
par exemple de simples militants anti
gouvernement selon les caprices d'un
algorithme d'un espionnage de drones et
les cérémonies en hommage aux victimes
du 11 septembre on en parle avec kenneth
timerman ancien conseiller aux affaires
étrangères de donald trump
qaîda timerman bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france peut-être
un mot sur votre sentiment aujourd'hui
après ces hommages à new york
écoutez
du pression qui m'a ému et a toujours
dicté et durant sa présidence d'être
incapable de parler d'être incohérent et
en fait c'était de la poésie il a parlé
de notre âme en tant qu'américains il a
parlé de nos meilleurs espoirs en tant
qu'américains et en fait c'était un
discours très impressionné
impressionnant surtout quand il a été
suivi par servi de cadre à le novice la
vice-présidente américaine qui a dit que
l'unité était une imposition l'unité
s'imposer comme si elle était à la tête
d'un état de dictature la dictature
c'est à dire qu'effectivement un appel à
l'unité d'un côté et et puis de l'autre
on a entendu le président donald trump
qui a à dénoncer l'incompétence de joe
biden dont la gestion du retrait des
troupes américaines d'afghanistan
mais évidemment et cela on en parle
depuis deux semaines ici trois semaines
c'est exécrable
by a fait à un hommage et la réputation
des etats-unis
la capacité de 10 soit des attaques
contre les états unis cette façon
permanente de talibans aujourd'hui même
le 11 septembre a décrété le début de
son khalifat à kaboul c'est à dire il a
célébré les attaques du 11 septembre on
en faisant rentrer au gouvernement
exactement les mêmes personnes qui
étaient là en 2001 au début de tout
c'est cette histoire bein nous avait
fait marche arrière de 20 ans nous
sommes également aux états unis le 10
septembre 2001 de terribles toujours au
pouvoir al qaida toujours
hébergés et est hébergée en afghanistan
et nous personne ne croit ne croit plus
à la dissuasion américaine un échec de
la politique américaine en afghanistan
on parlait il ya quelques instants du
patriot act qu'en est-il sur le
territoire américain aujourd'hui où en
est finalement la menace terroriste est
ce que ce patriot act as a finalement
permis de lutter contre le terrorisme
sur le territoire américain
oui et non au début tout de suite après
2001 le patriot act a aidé parce qu'il a
permis de dépister les réseaux locaux
céder aux états unis qui étaient en
correspondance avec les réseaux d'al
qaïda à l'étranger mais il fallait moi
j'étais je supportais gt1 je soutenais
le patriot act
au début comme la plupart des hommes de
gauche et de droite aux états unis à
l'époque mais le henson et nous cia et
des autres la pia et aussi ils ont
par leurs propres actions ils se sont
discrédités et ils ont montré qu'il
était capable d'espionner tout le monde
pour n'importe quoi l'histoire le plus
accablantes c'était l'espionnite
qu'entre d'entre eux durant la campagne
de 2016 ils ont écouté pas seulement ses
communications électroniques s'est
téléphoné cet art mais celle de tous ses
conseillers et de cette matière hier
cette barrière de base ils ont construit
une panoplie de charges criminelles
contre un président en exercice de
pouvoir qui est incroyable et qui était
complètement d'ailleurs dé prouver ses
dires ces accusations sont caduques il
n'est pas bien fondé et je pense
maintenant il n'y a plus beaucoup de
soutien pour le patriot act ni au
congrès ni surtout dans le public on
arrive à la fin de ce journal merci
beaucoup en tout cas kenneth timerman
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce soir
en direct sur rt franc je le rappelle
vous êtes ancien conseiller aux affaires
étrangères de donald trump et c'est la
fin donc de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi ont fait un prochain point
complet sur l'actualité dans une
trentaine de minutes rester avec nous
sur rt france
[Musique]
certains font entendre leur voix pour
les autres et le silence qui parle
[Musique]
est-ce qu'à une période de stabilité en
haïti est ce que ça a été est ce que ça
existe et je la fais plus de cent ans
que l'on avait assisté à l'assassinât
d'un président de la république en haïti
l'état de roaa et et véritable